Let's have a look at the HTML first.
I see a FIXME here,
there's a role for that.
Let's go have a look at
the aria roles we can use.
All right, dialog seems like a good fit.
A dialog is an application window that
is designed to interrupt the current
processing of an application in order to
prompt the user to enter information or
require a response.
Let's add that role and
see how it changes things.
Now with ChromeVox Lite running, when I
click the Sign in button, it tells me,
Entered dialog,
Log in to Kangaroo Kilometers Dialog,
Frequent flyer number, Edit text.
How did it know the name of the dialog?
Yeah, it already had
an aria-labelledby attribute on there,
pointing at the heading.
But at this point,
if I were to Shift+Tab backwards,
I would see that I could still jump
out of the dialog and into the footer.
If we look at the DOM, we can see why.
The dialog is placed
after the page content.
So if we work backwards from the dialog,
we'll end up at the end
of the page contents.
Let's have a look at
the JavaScript here then.
There's a comment down here saying hide
non-modal content from screen readers.
Perhaps aria-hidden would
be a good fit here.
So let's give that a shot.
We'll add a line here, looking for
that wrapper element, and
set the aria-hidden attribute to true.
Then of course,
we need to remember to set it back
to false once the dialog is closed.
Since the default value for
aria-hidden is false,
we can just remove the attribute.
Now let's see if that worked.
With ChromeVox Lite running,
I can open the dialog again.
And working backwards from this text
field, I go to the Log in button,
which is exactly what I would expect.
The focus is locked to just this dialog.
Awesome.
And if I close the dialog, the focus
goes back to the Sign in button,
exactly where we started this process.